So we've seen how to use recursive definitions to make words and to define concepts like ancestors
Now we are gonna see how to use recursive definitions to define a procedure
and we are gonna start with a procedure that we already defined in Unit 2
We defined the factorial procedure
and we defined factorial as the numbers of ways that we can order n items
and the input is the number n
and that could be calculated by multiplying n times n-1 times n-2 and so on
until we get down to the 1
So that definition is not very precise mathematically
and the problem with this as a mathematical definition is it got these dot dot dot in it
and human sort of understand that correctly what that dot dot dot means
but it's not a very precise mathematical definition
If we use a recursive definition, we can define factorial in a much more precise way
and we need to do that by giving a base case
So for the base case, we wanna think about the simplest input
something that we already know the answer
And for factorial and for many procedures that involve numbers
the simplest input is the number 0
So if we try factorial 0
the number of ways to arrange 0 things is defined as 1
So we know that result
That's gonna be our base case
Now all we need to do is define the recursive case
where we want to define what's the meaning of factorial for any number n is
where n is any integer greater than 0
And we can define that in terms of the factorial of the smaller numbers
So if you look at this definition with the dot dot dot
where we see that the factorial of n is n times n-1 and so forth
Well, this what we have here is actually the factorial of n-1
So that means that we can define the factorial of n as n times the factorial of n-1
and that's our recursive case
And this definition matches our intuition well
if we think about factorial meaning the number of ways to arrange n objects
This corresponds exactly to the way we think about this
that we have n ways to pick the first item
and once we picked the first item, well we have n（actually he means n-1） items left
and factorial n-1 gives us the number of ways to arrange the remaining n-1 items
So that's the way to define this mathematically
So now I will leave it to you as a quiz to figure out how to define a procedure
that computes factorial without using a while loop